d'où viens avec ma fille non
non plus sans commenter un peu plus
pourquoi mahdi question simple on s'est
alors développé
avec maintenant depuis cinq ans il dit
qu'on n'existe pas qu'on ne sert pas à
grand chose on s'est opposé la nuit sur
bien des sujets sans être franchement et
de thénia l'assemblée ni au sénat
comment après vous allez expliquer à nos
électeurs font pas du vernet avec macro
si on gouverne avec macron dès demain
par un très bien aux prochaines
élections tout ce qui est en train de
passer rassemblement national il ya plus
d'existence de la prom'classic donc nous
ne sommes pas des va-t-en-guerre donc on
va pas mettre le feu à la maison on
respecte les institutions on votera cas
par cas sur les textes de loi et cetera
on ne votera évidemment pas de motion de
censure elle est fille au moment de la
déclaration de gouvernement et je ne
vois pas pourquoi on n'en fait plus et
vit toute façon chaque fois vous nous
poser la question est ce que vous êtes
prêt à metz que lui est prêt à parce
qu'on ne voit jamais on ne voit jamais
de gènes de la part du président l'a
doublé dia jean françois copé lui d'
écoute tu n'arrêtes pas nous dire on
fait un pacte ont fait machin d'accord
mais moi je ne vois jamais de gestes de
la part du président de la république
qui ne s'est pas exprimée hier soir qui
s'est pas exprimée ce matin il attend qu
elle mais si mais si vous trouvez un
masque vous l'apprenez mais quelle main
il attend attendre à part nous dire
le gouvernement actuel ne peut pas
rester rond je propose un gouvernement
d'union nationale ou un gouvernement de
cohabitation
mais ce qui n'est pas allé jusque là
pour moi il n'a rien et donc ne venait
pas que vers nous nous dire mais vous
alors que vous allez faire pas et lui
fait quoi
de luge attend rien donc je vais citer
jean françois copé vous avez cité
jean-françois copé jean-françois
l'impact du gouvernement
minoritaire c'est une évidence au comité
stratégique nous c'est extrêmement
simple y aura des textes à la retraite
si vraiment il est déposé pour petra y
aura des textes peut-être sur la
sécurité qu'on acceptera puis un autre
texte qu'on n'acceptera pas alors le
gouvernement fera avec de les faire du
cas par cas du cas par cas mais ça
ressemble bloquer le système puisqu'on
ne vaudra pas de motion de censure à
l'effi mais
bon c'est pas plus mal
on est les oiseaux libres regarder les
filles de 2012 2017 induits et u7 à
l'assemblée jean pied de port
vous avez l'impression qu'elle doit
trois premiers l'avaient finalement que
la droite reprend du poil de la bête à
la droite doit se recomposer se
reconstruire parce que pour nous c'est
pas un succès 1 en à 60 65 sièges dans
la commune perdu 35 donc on n'a rien à
glorifier d'hier soir mais voilà la
situation instaurée on prend acte que la
vraie percée c'est celle du
rassemblement national parce que les
autres du ps à 140 ou 150 c'est le
regroupement de toutes les gauches mais
97 mais en attendant moi j'aurais aimé
le prétend la république nous disent le
vote d'hier c'est mort né le conseil
national la refondation mort né le
toutes les tentatives de mise en place
de la proportionnelle mornet la réforme
institutionnelle qui l'avait envisagé
après on peut en parler
oui je la torre jean-françois il fait ce
qu'il veut après sa position n'est pas
celle de la formation politique et si
vous continuez de l'inviter comme s'il
était le représentant
votre affaire et lui il ya l ombre
galets mais c'est pas le point
aujourd'hui votre intérêt cette série
lance et chacun fait ce nouveau chat
serrer les rangs vous voyez vous c'est
terminé la droite qui dit non mais non
on se parle chacun a une position on
verra tout à l'heure mais je pense que
la position sera cas par cas pas de vote
de motion de censure et les fics et au
président la république de prendre des
initiatives parce que franchement on l'a
déjà pas beaucoup entendue depuis le 24
avril et à la formation du gouvernement
on l'a pas entendu depuis hier soir tout
ce qu'on a c'est madame elisabeth bornes
qui dit ça va être dur mais
aura aura deux possibilités
non mais justement à la confiance on
nous dit qu'il ya une notion qui
censurent gré les filles comme on votera
pas la motion de censure à l'effi
voilà merci
[Musique]